where did everybody go
for whatever reason you are the last
human on earth so what do you do eat
like a king move into Buckingham Palace
drive fast blow things up be naked all
the time or would you pretend you
weren't alone
how long would you last this is what if
and here's how you can survive as the
last person on earth so you wake up one
day and find you're the only person left
in the world kind of cool right no
obligations no rules no limits
go nuts step 1 enjoy the good things
while you can go for the exotic fruits
first if your mangos and bananas are
imported from overseas chances are
they'll be hard to come by so eat them
while you can and enjoy every last bite
step 2
find a secure source of fuel you might
think that with no one stopping you you
could go anywhere but not so fast all
those abandoned cars boats and planes
you see lying around will be useless in
about two years when their fuel goes
stale guess you'll be sticking around
but for how long
step 3 find a place to live if water
food and shelter are your basic needs
shelter would be the easiest to come by
you'd literally have a world of homes to
choose from but be careful where you
settle down cities would become
dangerous since without proper
maintenance they'd start to fall apart
pretty quickly nature's elements rain
frost and heat would take the toll rot
and mold would become widespread and
vegetation would crack through concrete
and break through glass but even if you
were able to fight back against nature's
reclamation of the land all it takes is
one bolt of lightning to start a
citywide fire and you can't call the
fire department so run for the hills
step 4 get yourself some protection
even the country isn't all that safe
first of all there are predators you
need to defend against wild dogs feral
cats bears but you'd only have to worry
about them as long as you could still
breathe there are more than 400 nuclear
power plants in the world
and once they're automated safety
systems began to fail without human
supervision that would be meltdowns
across the planet rendering many regions
simply uninhabitable step 5
find some food in terms of food the city
would be your best bet
supermarkets have enough canned and
frozen food to last you for decades
whereas in the country crops and
livestock would start to dwindle without
proper care or protection from predators
but if natural is more your style you'd
have to go back to the old ways of
hunting with a spear or bow since
ammunition would be limited and harder
to come by maybe you could grow your own
little vegetable garden but that would
cut into your water resources
step 6 it's all about the water without
other humans you'd be without
electricity water pumping stations and
treatment works would shut down and the
fresh water kept in reservoirs would go
stale quite quickly you could rely on
bottled water and you'd probably have
thousands of liters to go through but
eventually you'd have to learn how to
purify your own
step 7 start learning
you'd have to teach yourself a lot of
things but lucky for you you've got a
lot of time on your hands and millions
of books out there with all the
information you'd need to survive
effectively on your own so while it
might be hard at first you could
technically survive as the last human on
earth but would you really want to
humans evolve together as social
creatures in order to survive we joined
forces against hunger and harsh weather
and built families and communities to
share stories empathize and keep each
other happy and healthy human contact
has been scientifically proven to build
trust and reduce stress so while it's
apt to cramp your style be glad it's a
small world we need each other more than
you think
[Music]